so we have here on this number line that
we've now marked off with the tenths and
you can see that this is three tenths
here
we can think about this as a
multiplication of a decimal and so what
is this representing and i'll give you a
hint it's representing something times
three tenths so pause the video and try
to think about that
well let's see
we are going one times three tenths two
times three tenths
three times three tenths and then four
times three tenths so what's represented
here is four
times
three tenths
and so what is this going to be equal to
well you can see you go from three
tenths to six tenths to nine tenths and
then you could do this as twelve tenths
but twelve tenths is the same thing as
one one and two tenths so you could view
this as one point two one and two tenths
let's do another example now actually
i'll do it on the same number line if we
wanted to represent
three
times
three times 0.2
what would that look like on this number
line and what would this be equal to so
i'll put a little equal sign here
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right so let's think about where 2
tenths is this is 1 10 2 10 is right
over there this is 0.2 and we're going
to multiply it times 3.
so we're going to multiply it times 1
then we're going to multiply it times 2.
that takes us to 4 tenths and then we're
going to multiply it times 3 to get us 2
six tenths 0.6
so it's 6 10 just like that now you can
also visualize two tenths as parts of a
whole
so for example this represents two
tenths i have this whole the square is a
whole it's it's split into ten equal
columns here and we have two of them
filled in so this represents two tenths
so if you have three times two-tenths
well this is one times two-tenths this
is two times two-tenths and this is
three times two-tenths and so how many
tenths do we now have well we have one
two three four five six tenths which is
exactly what we have here six tenths
let's do one more example that gets a
little bit more involved
so here we're told to multiply it says
you may use the model shown to help find
the product and this is a screenshot
from the exercise on khan academy so
pause this video and see if you can
figure out what this is
all right so they're saying 52
hundredths times 3 and they have 52
hundredths depicted right over here and
then they have it depicted three times
so the total number of hundredths
depicted here that is 52 hundredths
times 3 because we have 52 hundredths
here another 52 hundredths and then
another 52 hundredths so how many
hundredths is that going to be
well you could view this as 52 times 3
and that will give you the number of
hundredths we have so let's think about
this so if we were to just say 52 times
3 well this is going to be 2 times 3 is
equal to 6 and then 5 tens times 3 is 15
tens which is the same thing we could
either just write it as 15 tens or
that's 105 tens but either way if i have
52 of something and i multiply that by 3
i now have 156 of that something and
here the something is hundredths so if i
say 52 hundredths hundredths
times three that's going to be 156
hundredths
and how do we represent 156
hundredths well there's a couple of ways
to think about it if this is the ones
place this is the tenths place this is
the hundredths place well we would write
the 6 there the 5 there and the 1 there
so you could recognize this as hey look
a hundred hundredths let me color code
it a hundred hundredths is the same
thing as a whole
and i'll circle that in red
and
fifty hundredths is the same thing as
five tenths and of course six hundredths
is the same thing as six hundredths so
this is going to be equal to we could
say one point five six or you could view
this as a hundred fifty six hundredths
so you could view this as a whole which
is a hundred hundredths and five tenths
which is fifty hundredths and six
hundredths